and I tell you hair tonics they're
always a scam hey there folks overdo
doctor who reviewed time and we are now
up to Planet of the OOD before we get
into it though this is your little
reminder that this particular episode of
Council of geeks is sponsored by radio
versus the Martians it's a podcast
series that features Mike Gillis and
Casey Doran as they run down basically
whatever geeky stuff they feel like
talking about that given conversation
and they have all kinds of guests they
talk about Star Wars and Game of Thrones
and comic books and Batman and wrestling
and Arnold Schwarzenegger seriously
they're watching every Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie is kind of amazing
so that's radio versus the Martians
radio versus the marshes calm or
wherever you get your podcast thanks
guys so Planet of the OOD Donna Nobles
first off world experience and this was
one that I wondered if I was gonna find
more enjoyment out of it than my memory
of it was kind of a bit like what
happened to me with fires of Pompeii
which I never disliked but I think I got
a lot more out of it on this rewatch
than I did originally whereas with this
um not quite I came away about as I
remembered which was yeah that basically
works but there's there's a lot of
nitpicky things about this one for me
for various reasons and there are things
that I don't always know if I should be
calling the show out for but sometimes
that's the nature of a nitpick like I
don't know why this is bugging me but
it's bugging me and there's a fair
number of them here but before I get
into that I mean what's good hey Donna I
mean like Kathryn tastes so good in this
part and her and Tennant they just they
big
on screen phenomenal and I love I love
the the PR woman you know is a oh um dr.
noble misses over there like no no we're
not together and Donna's like no never
ever but the emphasis on that I really
really do enjoy it is nice that the you
sort of get picked up on given that the
fact that the great what is it second
great and bountiful human Empire has a
slave class got established a couple
seasons ago and never really picked up
on yeah this was a thread worth Tuggy on
and getting some more stuff out of plus
I I like the design of the you'd I've
always liked the design of the you do is
one of the first things that really
grabbed my attention about Doctor Who is
a show so I'm happy to see them back the
performances for the most part actually
worked pretty well um a fair number of
the I mean there's there's like one
really iffy performance but I'll mention
that at the when I when I start getting
into my net picks and my complaints but
for the most part the performances are
from the guest cast are solid
you know the are very stoic but they're
I feel like one of the more convincing
alien races they exude a surprising
amount of personality especially given
that they're really kind of not meant to
have any but it they still they don't
feel robotic they feel like there's
something going on there and especially
here where you get to contrast the wild
ood with rabid with someone like who
would Sigma there's a surprising amount
of variety in something that has very
little movement in his face so that
works really well you've got the the guy
who heads the whole company that was a
surprisingly detailed performance then
and there was a there was a little tiny
detail that I think I caught it before
but I'd forgotten which is when like
he's made the decision to just wipe this
stock and and start over and he's he
turns to Sigma who's his personal ode
and he says you know you're loyal to the
end go join your people and it's
it's that illusion and that projection
that a slave owner has on like oh all
these savages who I think nothing of and
I think so little of them that I treat
them as property instead of sensing
human beings but that one there I kind
of like them I still treat them as
property but I kind of like them and
like for the episode doesn't get into
this but you know that's that's how
people like that
sleep at night I don't treat all of them
like that
what about Hertz Sigma I like him yeah
but you're still terrible the PR woman
was quite good I like that that they she
has a moment where the doctor you know
basically has his moment to talk her
into getting on the right side of things
and she doesn't because the doctor can't
convince everybody and usually when the
doctors not going to talk somebody into
doing something it's clear right off the
bat there isn't that moment of oh maybe
they will oh no wait they didn't that
hadn't really happened too much up to
this point so that was a good moment I
like that too
but okay so as I said most of what I'm
about to complain about here are
nitpicks they're not massive structural
problems which are the sort of things
that will totally sink an episode for me
the kind of nitpicks that I'm about to
go into are more the things that will
take a decent episode and just make it
middling which is pretty much what this
becomes it's not a bad episode I don't
dislike it but here's some of the stuff
that bugs me first of all I mentioned
there's one performance that I don't
think is very good and that's the head
of security what is it with security
heads in these things always being just
psychotic people and like he's
controlling that claw trying to grab the
doctor and he's like what are you do oh
god it was so hammy and like Doctor Who
can have hammy acting and it's sometimes
it can even work
I honestly think that's a minority but
sometimes it can actually work but not
when you're also doing an episode trying
to make a point about you know
it's slavery basically and like even
going so far as to make parallels to
exploited workers on earth explicitly
drawing a having the doctor explicitly
draw that parallel and you've got this
goofy hammy security head no doesn't
clash a tones does doesn't mix right
there in addition to that so okay I
generally tend to give a pretty decent
amount of leeway for alien races that
don't seem to make sense
basically largely because I'm willing to
accept that whatever it is that doesn't
make sense to me initially probably does
if I knew more about them but for the
purpose of the story we only learned so
much but there's something about the
food here that really bothers me and
it's because of something that the
doctor points out in the first place but
then what happens later really seems to
contradict that so part of why the
doctor starts sniffing around is he says
a slave race could have never evolved on
its own so that's how he comes to the
conclusion that they've been subjugated
because no race would just be sitting
around needing orders which fair accept
what we then later learn about food I
have a hard time believing that evolved
naturally either so the idea of a
forebrain and hindbrain I get that I can
roll with that I remember you know
learning about dinosaurs with hind
brains when I was in grade school is
like cool but it's external they have to
carry it they have to occupy their
appendages at least one of which now has
no other use and like it's it's like a
brain it's squishy its vulnerable so
your logic for why they must be
subjugated is because the slave race
would never evolve but like this thing
with this external brain evolved
naturally and and the in the way even
dark even Donna puts it it's it you know
they're born with their brain in their
hands they're gonna trust anyone who
lands like
how is that any different from having
been like it evolved slavery's I I just
I that there's a there's a disconnect
here for me between what is pinging the
doctors radars being wrong and what I
then get presented as well this is what
it really is and I'm like what and I
honestly this might only bother me
because I've never seen anybody ever
complain about this but uh okay couple
more nitpicks to register one very minor
and one honestly bothers me and has
bothered me since I first saw this
episode so the OOD saying this is the
minor one I wish it had been more alien
because it just kind of sounds like
opera which I operas fine but I wish it
could have sounded more unique more like
something otherworldly and because it's
sound because it sounds like something
so identifiable it unfortunately takes
Catherine Tate wonderful performance of
the impact of hearing that song and
dampens it slightly because I'm like
that's just opera why is she crying so
you know that that kind of throws me off
a little bit now the thing that really
bothers me and again I give this show a
pretty decent leeway I really try to
avoid pedantic like technical and
biological nitpicks but dude and humans
are not
we don't even share a common ancestor
how do you transform a human being
into an ood like that's not science
fiction that's magic and just know I
don't I don't buy it
I just don't that entire ending segment
like somatically I get it but
logistically it's a step too far he
completely changed species like down to
the DNA level like ya know so the little
nitpicks like that hold this episode
back for me which again is a bit of a
shame because there is good stuff here
and the performances aside from those
data security are all solid so it I get
annoyed with myself when smaller things
like this pile up and davon my
entertainment on something cuz I don't
like to be that person who just doesn't
really have substance and complaints but
just a list of nitpicks
I don't like being that way but
sometimes that's just what I come away
feeling and that's kind of where this
one leaves me plenty you seen it what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it subscribe
like yeah I guess that's driving the
algorithm right now is the like so
please in addition to that you know
links for stuff like the patreon the
support really helps keep thing going
and you know my social media is there's
merch there's also just a ton of links
down there go ahead and click on them
you also don't have to cuz at the end of
the day you are the council I'm just
running the meetings look I'm pretty
good doing it too and until next time
this council is adjourned
what was that bomb at you narcissistic
jackass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]